(upbeat music)
Incoming bonus content.
Hi, I'm Casey Wilson.
And I'm Danielle Schneider.
And we are gonna do the Best Friend Challenge.
I'm doing a tie.
Okay.
Okay, one, two, three.
I had Porsha first.
Ah, and Sonja, I would've said Sonja.
Porsha is the matchup,
but Porsha is the greatest housewife.
She's the greatest house.
I mean, I think these two are the greatest housewives.
And I would've said Sonja too,
if I knew we could do two, I would've said Sonja.
Hidden?
Hmm.
All my talents are so--
They're out there.
The world enjoys all my talents.
So it's hard to pick one talent when you have so many.
Okay, ready?
What did you say?
Perfect pitch.
Ah, that's not hidden.
Okay, well, I don't have perfect pitch.
Decorating?
That's so nice.
You're a really nice decorator.
Thank you.
I think you have beautiful designs.
I wish I had put that because that's so nice.
One, two, three.
(group laughs)
When you are someone, you are them.
Yeah, but just the essence.
The raw essence.
(group laughs)
Not a dog.
I just find dog people like their dogs will jump up
in your face and lick you all over.
And they're like, do you mind dogs?
Get your dog off me.
I put sexy lynx.
How dare you.
You couldn't pick a lynx out of a lineup.
(group laughs)
I coulda put anteater.
Anteater?
I don't know, that was a hard one.
I feel like mine were the most right.
Yeah, you're right.
And that was a little bit extra for you.
(upbeat music)